- Good morning Believe Nation,
today's message is Be Driven.
Over to you, Shakira.
(roosting crowing)
♫ I wake up every mornin'
♫ Espresso keep me goin'
♫ I wake up every monrin'
- You know I grew up in Columbia.
And Columbia is a developing country
where a lot of people don't
have access to the most
basic needs and where education
is considered a luxury.
Unfortunately because we
all know that education is
a birthright and I just
grew up frustrated seeing
how many people weren't able
to realize their own dreams.
When I was eight years old,
my dad over went an economic
crisis, a financial crisis,
he lost his business.
And we struggled
economically for many years.
We lost our car, we lost our furniture.
And I remember vividly the
day I walked in my house
and all the furniture was
gone because my dad had
to pay his debts and it was
quite well, shocking for me.
I was eight, seven, eight years old.
And when I saw this I was so frustrated
and so upset with my
parents because I couldn't
understand how they did
so poorly in business.
I'm like, why, why, I couldn't get it.
And my dad and my mom took me to the park
where they showed me other
kids my age sniffing glue.
They were orphans, they had
no one to watch after them
and they were barefoot and
they were abandoned to their
own luck and it probably
left such an impression
in my impressionable mind
at that age that I remember
that day and I remember that
I made myself a promise.
I said to myself, Shakira,
you have to succeed.
Because you have to ride
in a car again, one day.
You have to get your own car someday.
And I wanted to vindicate
my parents socially
and economically and I
also wanted to someday
do something for those kids
who I saw that day in the park.
So as soon as I had my
first big success with
Pies Descalzos which was my third album,
I decided to establish my own foundation
and do my own contribution to the change
even if it was going to be a small one.
But I wanted to be active and
that's how it all started.
Going through my own financial struggle
and the struggle of my
family and understanding
that the one thing that
I never lacked was care,
protection and an education
and that's probably
what made me thrive in life.
- Having a why is so
important to accomplishing
any big thing, especially
having success in business.
You have to know why you're
doing something if you're
going to continue, too many
people start a business just
because they're trying to make money.
You may be in debt, you
may need to pay your bills.
So I'm going to start a company to do it.
It's not a strong enough
why, what ends up happening
to the people that are
just motivated by money,
what they do is they
start a company, sometimes
they'll have success, they'll
make a little bit of money,
just enough to pay their
bills and then they ease off.
They ease off the throttle,
they stop pushing hard.
Because they've paid off
their bills until the bills
come again and then they work harder.
And these people who
are motivated by money
are just living paycheck
to paycheck to paycheck
to paycheck and they never
get the money they're after.
You have to understand what
it is that you stand for
and what big thing you're
trying to accomplish.
If you can't make that
connection to the work you're
doing every day, guess what,
you're going to stop working.
You're not going to put
everything you've got into it.
'Cause there's no strong why behind it.
When I look at my first
business, I struggled a lot.
Right, I was making $300 a
month, barely able to survive
and I told my partner that I quit.
You guys have heard the story
a couple times probably.
I told my partner that I quit.
And I woke up the next
day and I'm like, I'm not
going to be a quitter, I
need to see this through.
I don't want to live the
rest of my life in regret.
I had a situation the year
before where there was a moment
that I regretted not taking
actino when I should've.
I was afraid, I didn't have the courage.
So I didn't take action and
I took a picture of that
moment and I hung it on my
wall as a reminder to myself
that the next time I want
to do something and I'm too
afraid to do it, I have to
go and take that chance.
Because the regret will eat you up.
'Cause I can deal with it not working out.
I can deal with the failure
but I can't deal with
not knowing, the immediate
pain of rejection or failure
sucks but it's nothing
compared to the lifetime of
regret you'll have always
looking back on that moment
and knowing you should've done something.
So I went back to my company,
after that first experience,
I went back to my business
because I didn't want to leave
feeling like I could do a little bit more.
I've got a little bit more in
me, I didn't want to live with
regret, what's your why,
if you are not getting up
daily and pounding on
your business, you don't
have a strong enough why so tap into it.
What is it, what do you
stand for, what are you
trying to build, why is it
so important that's it's
a must for you to go out
and accomplish today?
And I would put that
into my daily routine.
You wake up, at least for
me, I need to reset everyday.
You wake up and start
thinking about why am I doing
what I'm doing, why am I doing
what I'm about to do today?
Why is it so important to me?
And if you can't come up
with an amazing reason,
you're going to mail in today,
you're just not going to work hard.
You're going to do enough to
get by and you're going to be
one of those people who
lives paycheck to paycheck
to paycheck, you want to
increase your standard of living.
You want to increase the impact
that you're having on the
world, you want to increase
your level of fulfillment
and happiness, have a more important why.
So the question today is what is you why.
Leave it down in the comments below,
super curious to find out.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Figrie Rahman.
Thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my
book, Your One Word, it
really, really, really
means a lot to me and I hope
you're enjoying the read.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you, I hope
you continue to believe
in yourself and whatever your one word is.
Much love and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of Ent Spresso.
(funky music)
♫ I wake up every mornin'
♫ Espresso keep me goin'
- If you really have a
drive and you really put
your heart and soul into something,
you can really make anything happen.
I'm a true believer in
that so I think that
hopefully we make people
believe that they can
achieve the American
Dream too, just watch,
study us and if you really are passionate
and driven, you can get there.
My true feeling is this,
no matter who you are.
No matter what age you are,
no matter the time in your
life, if you have a dream
and you have the drive,
you can make anything
happen and if you are ever
feeling down or feeling
like you can't get over
that hump or you just have
a bad day, I play this song.
And you remember this
song, okay, here it goes.
("Girl On Fire" by Alicia Keys plays)
(applause)
- I grew up within Hip Hop culture.
That's what I was immersed in as a youth.
That's what I was
surrounded by so naturally
that's what I gravitated
towards, you know what I mean.
If I grew up somewhere
else, maybe I would've
wanted to play guitar or like
sing folk songs or something.
But that was just naturally
what I gravitated to
because that's what I was surrounded by.
That was my world.
I don't know, I was into music.
Some kids were into
basketball, I wasn't very good.
So music was, I wasn't just
like a kid who ya know,
I don't know played video
games or just sat on the
computer all day doin' nothin'.
I was like a driven kid,
you know what I mean.
So music became my passion,
my vehicle for what
I was driven to do and naturally
it was what I was surrounded by.
- You once said in
interview that your life
is paranoia and fear and you're
just trying to not get hit.
- Yeah.
- Is that still true?
- Yeah, anger and fear,
fear of failure drives me.
Paranoia of things going
wrong around me drives me.
I am driven by a lot of really ugly anger.
And so I have a lot of that in me
and it comes from a
father who was terrifying
and teachers who yelled at me,
told me I'd never be anything
and so I descend from the
sky and land on things really
hard and I go at everything
with that amount of fury.
And I'm not saying I'm going
to hit anybody and I'm not
mad at you, I'm quite
happy to be here with you
and answer any question
to the best of my ability
but I go at everything
like, you think I can't,
hey, you want to try acting,
yeah, I'll try acting.
Can you act, no, so let's go.
(laughing)
- I've seen Sons of Anarchy, you can act.
- Thank you.
Fair is for losers, I'd rather win.
(whooshing)